[Music]
three two one action hey guys welcome
back to off-the-record where we talk
about whatever we want
okay I read a story coming in here today
about a billionaire who died because he
was getting his dick lengthen I saw that
too
we almost talked about it he's go to
penis enlargement you guys on then that
never came back
I didn't see it I read it I don't know
where I saw he needs another news source
I heard it on the radio on the radio in
Mirage oh okay rock dance oh he wanted a
heart you wanted a hard dick so bad that
he he died or a long day long day it's
like 65 years old or something - you
wanted a longer dick so they were
injecting yeah you want a longer dick so
they're doing penis enlargement surgery
and they're they're injecting something
into his dick and he had a heart attack
in time what do you need a big what do
you need it bigger for your billionaire
tell me it's a big woman tell me it's
big I know just tell me and make it
convincing and it doesn't matter pretend
the gag on it for me that's it yeah it's
all this that just goes to show like
money is not everything a big dick is
yeah exactly he's a billionaire I mean
like it's like you could have anything
you want in the world and he's like but
there's this one thing that is kind of
true because I was telling this story
where uh when I was in boot camp
Sasa I was a former Marine mhm in boot
camp there's a super skinny dude right
ideas positive like five five five six
probably weigh like 110 pounds and then
we're peeing and there's like only about
ten nurdles and there's 80 dudes and we
have 60 seconds so there was like four
dudes to yura yura packing the
journalist trying to pee every time this
guy pees he would plop his dick out and
would dip straight into the water
because it was just so big it was like
this big long this long and then like
this wide oh and that is he it was huge
and Bart knows it's a survey so I know
this because I spent like three and a
half months with this guy right and so I
know how big his dick is - imprinted in
my brain and so we would do like these
assault exercises with like 50 pound
packs guns and stuff like that
and we would go up and he wasn't the
most athletic or the most heart charging
but anytime we go up there and I'm done
and I look back and I see him like
struggling and maybe
cry on my dam at least has a really big
day that's why he's going slow he had to
drag that around Bloods going to his
dick no matter what he does like you can
do [ __ ] like will do pool exercises
right were [ __ ] treading water with
whatever and you could even be like oh
so what helped me on my foot but his
dick is really big though you Johnny
because of his big maybe but it's like
having a big dick is almost like being a
billionaire the dude so like it is
that's the weird thing
that's the weeping women don't care no
one Abart I want a bark shirt that says
I couldn't stop thinking about how big
so I went to boot camp in 2003 you talk
about like it was just yes yeah that
guy's imprinted in boot camp memories
are like yesterday's special how big is
it so traumatizing big dick memories
last forever you're getting traumatized
and oppressed at the same time cuz
you're going through boot camp but
you're like wow I never knew this could
be that big and like different dick
sizes on different guy sizes you know
you'd think some dude oh man that guy's
like six three and that's like his dicks
like a institude then you see this guy
it's like a hundred twenty pounds he has
like the biggest thing I've ever seen
yeah you knew all their dicks different
[Music]
for science science if you would have
said that this science hat on yeah if
you ever walk in and that's happening
you just know it the moments been
waiting behind science it's the same
hand that picks up dog [ __ ] you know to
me I like to lower I like to explore and
figure [ __ ] out do love it of course abs
for science yeah
I'm opposing science we're not letting
it happen you are Joe I brought you
something what I brought you
Isaac book
those are so fun although they make it
on the same page
nothing's changed my son still he never
asked for money this week he was like
can I get 50 bucks 50 bucks is like Book
Fairs like pears to honey that's how I
used to ball out yeah yeah yeah the
first way to study didn't McDonald do
you come back from the doctor yeah I'm
calling out at the book fair was how you
stun it in elementary school that's true
I will say I'm gonna be a pretty cool
dad about that stuff but I am banning
anime why just completely banned from
dude there there there's an anime in
here look at how much I don't want my
kids to become anime kids like
cosplaying kids you don't like that no
exactly like all that [ __ ] it's not
gonna [ __ ] happen
there's whatever else they wanted they
want to be Harry Potter kids I'll be sad
about it but that's okay you're gonna be
great storytellers I do not like [ __ ]
animators I don't like Harry Potter man
yeah but that's what I'm I I just found
the movies all be the same movie I think
just finished yesterday he came home he
was so excited he's like mommy guess
what I have a surprise for you I was
like what happened what is it I couldn't
guess and I'm like just give me a hand
he's like he has to do with the book
like you finished Harry Potter the very
last book Wow what a nerd finished it's
taken me years to go through all these
but you roll he read like a page is
buggin year No so then she started so
I've always told him once he finishes
the whole series we'll go to Orlando not
Orlando Universal Studios to go check
out Harry Potter worlds and now he's
like I'm so excited
get that butterbeer is lit yeah that's
for one yeah Isaac's gonna love the
bunny he has four ones you should have
stopped it but okay one Maya bottom four
dude have you gone to the wand chooses
you ceremony she's the [ __ ] most
hilarious [ __ ] where is that so they did
in Harry Potter world they have a
[ __ ] professor comes out and he's
just like you know he's like an actor
but that's what happened in the movie
you know I know but it's so funny the
watch happened
person right in person they have this
professor guy come down and he's like
he's like and then he's like he goes
from all in oh yeah yeah
but the funny thing is you know that's
gonna happen again at 11:15 what does it
matter part 315 it's real what I love
about it though is that somebody like
Joe a smiley [ __ ] who's like
excited that they got picked right they
get handed the wand and then they
literally just just walk you to the cash
register no they don't get it's the
parents fault if they don't [ __ ] it by
in Jesus okay cuz the one shows them in
front of like 45 people so it's like are
you the parent who's like put it back
absolutely
so am i I would just just to teach a
lesson I could I could be a billionaire
if that [ __ ] happens I'm like [ __ ] that
[ __ ] [ __ ]
you have to pay for now you broke it
magic in that [ __ ] like well you gonna
have to pay for you just broke it in
half on your knees no I would I would be
like that but for my own personal joy
because the idea of happy they can't go
up to the register and to me saying
absolutely not whatever the
photographers would be Bibble yet it is
photographer that like kept forcing
everyone at the table because we're
there for a birthday to take pictures
and she made every single couple of
stuff like pose for different times and
we're all like okay like one was enough
she's like oh kiss do this and she's
like trying to make directing us and
include later she's gonna fill the photo
[ __ ] yeah so they well we're like okay
well were these gonna go whatever so
we're just enjoying each other's company
and then she comes back with the printed
photo she put it in like this frame
things like that step
yeah so we'd get all of like our seven
[ __ ] pictures and we're like okay
cool we're gonna keep this she's like
it's $22 like what she's a nun if you
guys want this and we'll like no nobody
wanted is it for Tim I think he bought
her he probably felt he was that guilty
parent that was like oh I would have
thrown it at her only because I didn't
like her sales tactic yeah I don't like
that [ __ ] they told me like hey I'm
gonna be taking some dope-ass photos and
after at the animal print them out would
you and it might it's gonna cost as much
is that cool I'll be like okay
no no they weren't even dulled like they
took some pictures of me and Jill and
Blackmore like we're dead or something
but the obligations part of the get a
part of the thing the guilt that you
feel is part of her sales tactic yeah I
would've felt much much better if she's
like hey would you be down to pay for
this I'd have been let's do it because
I'll do it for memories but if you just
take it and then just put it on my table
on my yeah it's like that [ __ ] deaf
as dude that comes around at the mall
these are [ __ ] candy with the ribbons
like I'm deaf give me money [ __ ] you
definite stamp artist but you have to
sign it yeah they don't know you didn't
want you didn't know you said I know
that's why I could say it cuz I'm not
scared to say it I'm not afraid to tell
a dead guy off yeah yeah that could be
tough because you can't hear [ __ ] you
dude that's one of the only ones like
people with hearing disabilities that's
one of the only ones where people get
angry at you for having a disability
because they're trying to communicate
with you and then you kick you can't
hear them and so you get mad you're like
I said this thing but like big they
can't hear very well but that's one of
those like afflictions that people
actually get pissed at you for having
yeah so interesting cuz me she's a blind
guy you're like awesome help him he
can't see what's in front of them yeah
you're not pissed at them yeah but then
when the person is deaf like I asked you
do you need help it's like they don't
understand English right I can read lips
[ __ ] that's real cool skill to learn
how to reading lips yeah
lot of people can do it that's what a
good cheese Massa says yeah good nosy
person so you could see what they're
saying no and then I
when I was younger - with me and my best
friend cause like we would have these
conversations like you just look at each
other you already know what's going on
but like sometimes there would be some
miscommunication so I'm like Tam I was
gonna be like just make random I met
random movement I was really good at
reading lips when my teacher was talking
to my parents and I was there or my
parents were like my mom was telling my
dad the bad [ __ ] I did that day I was
like oh [ __ ] she thought oh she's
telling him right now and I could really
read all everything she's saying do you
remember when kids did Pig Latin and I
was like [ __ ] this language my parents
do that all the time they do Pig Latin
Spanish yeah I hate it your false
offical go for more 4th FAF are a form
of us what does that mean I know what
your name is it sounds doper in Spanish
I will say because we didn't [ __ ] in
English it sounds like Harry Potter
names like hitting it a it ekeus yeah
yeah there's other ones like the googly
or some [ __ ] and that's why I don't like
Harry Potter taffy
you know that's Ponte spec difficut
these my teacher I'm like oh Jesus early
enjoyed it any kid any kid who's
Hufflepuff house needs to be [ __ ]
removed from society I like it movies
and stuff yeah of course so you just
don't like Harry Potter I just never got
into it yeah I never I mean I'm in the
same boat like Isaac loves it but I
never read the books I was never crazy
about the movies I'm just like that's
tight like have your childhood yeah no
III think he should have a childhood
never watching anime and you should ban
it from the house I watched it and I was
like you little [ __ ] but I couldn't
stop watching it the thing that was
crazy behind Potter world our world is
like JK Rowling have all that stuff in
her mind and it became books and movies
and freaking for real biggest part of
Universal Studios and that was all just
in there yeah and I was walking around
like that is in semi ancient the amount
of money there like literally printing
money for Harry Potter stuff cuz my son
was he's into a crazy and he wanted the
wand the
but I got it the one one was he chosen
you know I was just winging I know time
for all that get the one at Walmart you
don't even need to buy here from
universe smart but the robes and stuff
they were like $200 Wow I mean it was
like stitched it was like any people put
yeah they couldn't wait to buy it I mean
there were like 200 I mean it was just
literally like a cash machine oh yeah
much better cheaper but the ones itself
at Universal Studios
but the butterbeer is lit what's
butterbeer fire as far as they say it
tastes like it tastes like the best
cream soda you could ever have oh it is
amazing Jesus you just sold that to
everyone yeah I was at the grocery store
the other day and I saw [ __ ] you
wanna talk about ridiculous brand
tie-ins I saw Star Wars trash bags why
is it so it's like the chick from the
new Star Wars movies with a lightsaber
out and it's just a half the trash back
so that nothing is differed about the
trash bag it's just on the bus printed
with some sort of a Star Wars thing army
do they cost more because of that
yes dude they have like r2d2 on a
[ __ ] ziploc that's an amazing
franchise never get into it like the
original 303 but the first one is a new
hope yeah but even Return of the Jedi
kind of sucks like like okay the first
25 minutes are really good like the
Jabba the Hutt [ __ ] and then after that
when they go to Endor and the Ewok [ __ ]
is just so boring - no I think it's
because of our generation though
baseball baseball was dope yeah I think
it's because of our generation like that
was like next-level when it came out
yeah
I've already saw like what evolved from
that so going back as kids it was intact
but Empire Strikes Back was growls again
but then the ones that came out in the
90s
Oh for three yeah except the part
wouldn't know Anakin had his leg chopped
up I don't know it wasn't supposed to be
funny to me but it was hilarious like
barbeque me screaming yeah yeah
I got a doodle I do give me the focus
you got one good arm left I think I
think you made a bad choice here do all
the love scenes in the second one the
second prequel yeah yeah yeah are the
[ __ ] funniest [ __ ] where he's like I
love you as much as the Sun on Endor or
whatever it's like what your pretty bad
how am i bit we know we know what are
you absolutely talking about we know
what did I tell my wife I love her more
than Star Wars references for your love
wait does she [ __ ] about it
no because you guys have your [ __ ]
girl circle they do they had the girl
circle have a girl circle text nice men
initial bring your like [ __ ] poetic
cat oh he's like the prince charming of
a group like Nicky get the [ __ ] out yes
sorry
yeah very emotionally intelligent very
loving no he's judging me you knew me
huh I did he's his wife's number one
like her number one fan I am he makes
the rest of her looks
we look bad I like my wife he gives us
good advice stuff yeah thank God
so we going all the little writer's
retreat when we write films and stuff
Mikey always gives lots of good advice
that he could take back yep he does I
think he followed it for Valentine's he
did bring flowers no he did but he had
to because that day we fought getting
credit Addie's [ __ ] up you fallen
down [ __ ] up and then but he's still
falling but it kind of ruins the
following if you [ __ ] up exactly it's
like not even genuine anymore it's like
now you're in the doghouse now he has to
try harder so he's at a negative 10 yeah
get to a zero I know that's this case
you swung climbed out of a hole
basically that's it
not even know till halfway in yeah oh
[ __ ] what was the fight I don't even
remember it's so stupid you know super
no I yeah we all have stupid fights yeah
but I honestly can't remember it was
just in the morning right where's the VD
related was it like no no no dude he
gave me chocolate yeah you know
stop my god why would he stop by what
kind of [ __ ] up like and even as a guy
I noticed this so he got the flowers
brought it to tiff they went outside
they kissed happy Valentine's Day
everything is romantic [ __ ] hearts in
the air and all that right and I'm like
cool case he's killing the case he's
killing it then he goes uh oh wait um
you forget that garage door opener
because mine doesn't work and now my
[ __ ] now you just made it seem like the
only reason why you bought flowers you
got a lock out of your own house yeah
okay see the timing of this you could
have just went to Starbucks and worked
for six hours right and then maybe buy
her dinner and just completely ignore
that you needed to go back home you
didn't make dinner though I think it's
just tiny for sure it's kind of like
it's almost like here I bought you this
gift oh yeah can I borrow uh the vacuum
just give it a beat and then wouldn't
have seemed like a favor give it a beat
yeah just one beat give it to them let
them enjoy be happy to take a piss come
back or I can I borrow vacuum then I
feel way better it's you it's easy when
you see someone else to [ __ ] it up
absolutely oh yes guy what the immediate
when it's you it makes perfect I've bet
you in his head he was like doing his
thing and he was like oh yeah you know
like so he could have gotten the garage
door opener and all that but he has the
key to my car he could have gone in
without me even knowing - yeah oh I'm
good I see how it is to be married to
you now just like dang no cuz that still
talkin [ __ ] no cuz cuz of the way that
she explained it just now I was like all
day yeah cuz yard one of like a [ __ ]
million other things the whole Valerie I
blame you
wholesale I do Niecy is my book thank
you the [ __ ] off thanks girlfriend she
knows everything s everything
I know how mindless guys can be Oh
this morning I was using Jess's
toothbrush and I refuse to accept that
it was her toothbrush no hose just like
brushing my teeth are using my
toothbrush again I'm like no and I
turned around and my toothbrush is in
the shower and I'm like oh but I did one
of these things where I'm just like you
cover it with your hand I'm just caught
and I was frozen
I was literally frozen because I'll die
off you could have been like I miss you
so much I just want you in my mouth all
day girls hot hot I should've [ __ ]
went this and it start rubbing my balls
yeah and then you would have had sex and
then she would never know that you
[ __ ] up I was so blindsided though
because I'm like brushing my teeth and
I'm like for sure this is my [ __ ] did
you give her attitude no no I was just
like she's like is that my toothbrush
again and I'm like no again yeah I know
and then she's like I think it it what
and I'm like oh [ __ ] that's that's what
happened but I mean yeah like these
things don't happen when you're single
because there's no other person's
toothbrush to use you know
[Music]
[Music]